here's a tricky GRE test question of the  20 light bulbs in a box two are  defective an inspector will select two  light bulbs simultaneously and at random  from the box what is the probability  that neither of the light bulbs selected  will be defective express your answer as  a fraction  so we have 20 light bulbs of which two  are defective we want to know the  probability of selecting two light bulbs  at random of which both of them will be  working  so there are 18 working bulbs out of 20.  that's the chance the first light bulb  selected will be working  then once we've selected one light bulb  there are 19 light bulbs remaining of  which 17 will be working so we multiply  this by 17 over 19 and that gives us the  probability of 153 over 190. we can also  work from combinations we have 18 choose  2 because we're selecting two of the 18  working bulbs divided by 20 choose two  this also works out to be 153 over 190.